formation géographiques et sociales
cinquième année les conflits à la base
de cet exposé le dictionnaire de
géographie des éditions hatier le monde
contemporain comme par le passé et le
théâtre de multiples formes de conflits
qui peuvent avoir pour enjeu la maîtrise
d'un espace convoité
ce qui est particulièrement étudiée par
la géographie des conflits la carte kids
est proposé ici à l'écran qui est issu
de la classe du monde global de pascal
boniface et hubert védrine qui reste une
référence en termes d'analysé des
conflits et l'analyse du monde
contemporain vous offre une vue des
conflits tels qu'ils étaient en 2006 un
conflit du latin conflictuelle le choc
né de la rivalité pour un même objet du
moins deux acteurs ceux ci peuvent être
des individus mais aussi les groupes
sociaux ou des états les conflits
peuvent prendre des formes très variées
le plus souvent non armés le conflit
syndical par exemple mais aussi
l'embargo économique les conflits
peuvent déboucher sur la guerre qui donc
une des formes possibles de conflit le
terme de guerre désigne au sens strict
un conflit passant par une lutte armée
mais le terme est aussi employé dans le
langage courant pour évoquer des
conflits ne la remet utilisant par
exemple larmes économique ou
idéologiques voire informatique
le terme de cyberguerre ou cyberattaque
est encore mal définis mais désigne
selon l'otan une opération informatique
visant à prendre le contrôle d'un
système d'information dans le but de
blesser ou tuer des personnes ou encore
d'endommager ou détruire des objets ils
n'ont donc le et n'englobe donc pas a
priori tous les actes de piraterie
informatique vous avez une carte ici sur
votre droite qui illustrent les
différentes attaques mondiale
informatique
on distingue classiquement trois types
de guerre les guerres coloniales qui
sont désormais très marginale les
guerres interétatiques qui sont
également devenues rares en revanche 90%
des guerres sont à l'heure actuelle des
conflits intra étatiques à savoir des
guerres civiles celles ci sont toutes
mamans régression depuis les années 90
elles ont malgré tout engendrer la
création d'une trentaine d'états nouveau
dans le groupe depuis 1991 on insiste
donc un morcellement politiques de la
planète liés à la montée des
nationalismes qui a créé une situation
complexe et instable que l'on qualifie
parfois de balkanisation
ce terme est assez péjoratif il fait
référence au morcellement des balkans à
la veille de 1914 le terme s'applique à
des zones où les nationalismes sont
enchevêtrées et qui donne naissance
vraiment à une un éclatement d'un état
une partie de ces conflits et localisées
dans une zone qui va de l'afrique des
grands lacs en passant par l'afrique du
nord et la péninsule arabique jusqu'au
pakistan plusieurs géopoliticien et
organismes d'état parts de cette
constatation pour nommer cette zone
l'arc de crise ce terme su inventer à
l'époque de la chute du shah d'iran en
1979 par l'historien anglo saxons
bernard lewis et par ce biais que ce
président qui conseiller aux affaires
étrangères des états unis le concept d'
arc de crise reste très contestable car
la délimitation de cet arc varie en
fonction des auteurs une correspond en
fait à aucun ensemble géopolitique
particulier et englobe différents foyers
de violence et de crise qui sont dans la
réalité bien distincts les uns des
autres
ayant leur propre logique et parfois
aucun lien entre eux cependant nous
allons conserver ce terme d' arc de
crise car il nous semble intéressant
d'un point de vue pédagogique avec cette
représentation graphique des élèves ici
ici à la géopolitique pourront très
facilement localiser directement les
grandes zones d'instabilité à l'échelle
mondiale cette carte offre offre aussi
d'autres éléments intéressants
d'abord vous pouvez repérer les
différents conflits internes c'est à
dire une guerre civile et différents
conflits interétatiques actifs à l'heure
actuelle ou en tout cas en 2010 vous
pourrez remarquer aussi par cette icône
les différents pays qui ont connu le
printemps arabe
le printemps arabe pour rappel c'est un
mouvement de contestation qui va
traverser plusieurs pays dont visant à
remettre en cause le pouvoir de
différentes dictatures cette vidéo
touche à sa fin avant de le quitter
n'oubliez pas le quiz sur ce col j
vérifiez vos prises de notes
éventuellement noter les questions qui
vous semblent imposer lors de notre
prochaine séance de cours
et n'oubliez pas qu'une évaluation est
toujours possible en place à partir de
notes justement et après vérification de
celle ci cette matière évidemment fait
partie de la matière du court il sera
donc à revoir à la fois pour les
différentes productions que vous devrez
réaliser en place mais aussi bien sûr
pour les examens je vous souhaite un bon
travail et à bientôt